if you look at kind of the three biggest
criminal enterprises in the world right
now yes
arms dealing drugs and exotic animals
the exotic animal trade those are the
three biggest illegal trades right now
we can use 3d printing to print guns
already right that's already possible
there are people working on a 3d printer
for drugs right the idea is prescription
pharmaceuticals you could print them in
3d it's a chemistry set 3d printer
off-label use of this stuff is obviously
going to be the manufacturer of drugs
right synthetic biology lets us create
brand-new organisms from scratch so do
you want your exotic parrot or do you
want something that's brand new so
what's interesting about this and some
of this stuff is a little farther out
but over the next 20 25 years it means
that the three largest criminal
enterprises in the world are going to be
available to anyone right with 3d
printers with a DNA typewriter which is
sort of an at-home synthetic biology
interface so anybody can program DNA it
means that we're going to all the
illegal drug trades we're going to just
pull the rug out from underneath them
and nobody has any idea what happens
next right that's never happened before
and they said oh we've always had
organized crime because there's always
been stuff that we couldn't get that we
wanted well pretty soon we're gonna be
able to get whatever we want this is
kind of the weird side of the abundance
idea right when you live in a world of
abundance when we can use 3d printers
and synthetic biology and when anybody
can do it it means that a lot of the
illegal trades right the bottoms just
fallen out and what happens then we have
no idea
synthetic biology is progressing so
quickly right all kinds of new weapons
are now possible right one of the things
I look at in Tomorrowland is the
question of could you design a bio
weapon a synthetic by bio weapon that
targets the president's DNA alone it's
very very difficult to protect DNA right
it lasts a very very very long times a
long-lived molecule and it's everywhere
right every time you shake somebody's
hand
hand somebody a pen they're getting DNA
samples along the way the government is
already taking steps to protect the
presidential DNA right if the president
goes into public and he drinks a beer
out of a mug there's somebody there to
grab that glass afterwards
Hillary Clinton and this was released in
in some of the NSA stuff that Snowden
released told foreign diplomats that
they should secretly collect DNA from
foreign dignitaries so the United States
is already on the offense when it comes
to genetics I'd be very very surprised
if other countries weren't doing the
same back at us and it's going to become
more more of an issue so you know right
now we have to worry about all kinds of
assassinations by bullets and by bombs
and things along those lines
with what's coming I can make a disease
I can make a disease that I spray into
the air you pass through it nobody else
gets sick and you get a slow
neurodegenerative disease say that
unfolds over a couple years
nobody even knows you've been attacked
right they think you've just gotten sick
so we're looking at a whole new kind of
assassination and to think that you know
terrorists aren't going to be interested
in this technology is ridiculous every
time there's a new technology criminals
immediately take advantage of it and
this is the next technology so we're
going to start seeing criminals get
involved in it